to me the EU means democracy and
democracy to me means participation
justify certain other equal have our
voices heard in our opinion Church what
does the EU mean for young people that's
what the Parliament wanted to find out
on universal Children's Day young people
from 15 different member states came to
the European Parliament to pose
questions to a panel of some of the EU
s-- leading experts on children's rights
now hope that we will be able today with
all of you to really give you give you
the feeling that you have a voice in
shaping your future the future of
European Union the EU is collaborating
with UNICEF and euro child on a project
to actively involve children in the
future of the EU what actions have you
taken to address the migrant and refugee
crisis what inspiring lence waited you
to do your job and fight
equality and children rights can you
tell us how a day in the life of
President looks like EU Parliament
president Antonio Tajani announced that
the Parliament will now mark universal
Children's Day with a special event
every year this is the beginning of a
process promote debates promote
knowledge promote learning promote the
possibility to empower you to have a
voice to influence the decision making
process in Europe
[Music]